it roads blocked and almost nothing
visible the only way to reach Eastern
bosnia's remote villages is by air
helicopters delivered aid to mountainous
areas whose residents have been cut off
for days now the sick and vulnerable
airlifted to hospital lives have already
been lost and a state of emergency
declared there's no sign of any let-up
with more snow forecast and fears of
further casualties and disruption
Ukraine is among the country's worst hit
by Europe's big freeze ten days in more
than 130 people have lost their lives in
temperatures as low as minus 33 degrees
many of them were homeless forced to
sleep on frozen streets shelters like
this one in the capital Kiev provide a
much needed lifeline litter free food
many thanks to the people running the
shelter and all the staff who were
looking after us otherwise people would
die and it's good for us here here's
some of the city's most vulnerable
people can enjoy a hot meal and a little
respite from the cold meanwhile in
Romania fresh snow has brought with it
fresh problems transport disruption left
travelers to shiver in the cold those
drivers who decided to braid the roads
in their own cars had to get through the
ice and snow before setting off it was
the same story on the river Danube with
more than 90% of its surface frozen
icebreakers ships were brought in loaded
with supplies he bound for Black Sea
ports
in Rome which is also in the grips of
the Big Chill a first for Pope Benedict
as he addressed pilgrims in a
snow-covered sim Peter's Square also new
proteins the last time they had weather
like this in the Vatican was 27 years
ago while the snow might be something of
an inconvenience for the locals in Paris
for many tourists it just adds a little
extra genus equi my wife's birthday
today
so you'd be in Paris on her birthday any
snow is spectacular temperatures are
expected to stay low for the time being
and Europe's big freeze looks to be far
from over
geraldine Cooper Sky News